[Music]
Chuck I got some more explaining to do
ah
some long ago sometime I think we talked
about the rocket equation I want to talk
about that again but then take us into
space with it and talk about some other
stuff as well okay so you ready all
right so here you go
all right so if you're gonna drive from
New York to California right which I'm
now and you're still and you have you
know and you have and you have an
internal combustion engine car where
they're called ice cars in the in the
lingo by the way uh internal combustion
engine you fill up the tank with gas
until it's empty and then you fill it up
again correct then you fill it up again
so you till you get to California right
you have convenient filling stations
along the way all along the way just
little daggers in the heart of the Earth
all along the way now if you didn't have
those right you would need a single tank
big enough to get you to California
yeah a single tank okay
so we have to ask what does that tank
weigh
all right now if that tank weighs as
much as the car
and then some maybe then the fuel you're
burning in New York
part of that is just simply to move the
car
that's filled with fuels you haven't
burned yet
exactly such is the challenge with
rockets
because we don't have filling stations
in space
every ounce of fuel you burn
is to get the next ounce of fuel higher
up so that it could then burn afterwards
okay so let's let's run a quick
mathematical example you ready okay okay
but if I tell you it takes one pound of
fuel okay to put one pound of payload
into orbit suppose I want to put two
pounds of payload
I'm gonna need two pounds of fuel
no
you're gonna need a pound of fuel for
each of those pounds I need the fuel for
the fuel I need fuel the fuel the fuel
damn that's right
okay so I need a bow fuel for the pound
a pound of fuel for the fuel
for the fuel okay so now that's three
pounds of fuel fuel right to put get one
two pounds into orbit two pounds okay
now let's go three pounds of payload
okay so there's a pound each for each of
those that's three pounds right okay
plus a pound of fuel for each of those
three pounds of fuel so I need six
okay but wait
then
am I saying this right now then you need
a pound of fuel
or the fuel that's going to get the
three pounds of fuel into orbit the
point is that's right whether or not I
even explain that accurately
that you get the point here the point
here is that the amount of fuel you need
for every increment
of payload grows exponentially
and it's a famous equation called the
Rocket equation
right that's why if you saw the launch
of of either Apollo missions if you're
old-timer or the recent the recent
um Artemis missions right you see this
huge rocket and right at the top is the
Orion uh capsule and the service module
and the capsule it's way it's the little
thing at the top right everything else
is fuel because that has to go not only
to Earth orbit but to the Moon and back
and the astronauts are the payload plus
whatever the hell else they're taking up
there so so a more realistic calculation
would be uh 10 pounds of fuel for one
pound in orbit of payload right
that's more realistic so now two pounds
is
one it's you need a 10 pounds for that
extra pound of fuel plus 10 pounds of
fuel for the 10 pounds of fuel they got
the other pound of fuel okay so it's
crazy it's completely crazy
you would not need any of that if we had
illustrations in space yeah you just
need fuel to get to the next filling
station and then you refuel and then
keep going it'd be like driving across
the country and in this economy God I
tell you that's all I'm saying
[Laughter]
price of gas
okay so now here's an interesting fact
okay when you burn your
um
gasoline okay uh it how does it turn
into energy you remember
um there's a small spark it turns into
an explosion it pushes a piston it's a
spark right correct and the explosion is
the gasoline plus what
um they Infuse it with air or something
to like it's a it becomes a fear and
what's in the air that
oxygen yeah yeah so the air what's in
the air oxygen thank you so you have
gasoline plus oxygen makes energy okay
when it burns gotcha you got the oxygen
for free
it's just sitting there in there right
okay if I have a rocket
I wanted to leave the air
if I'm leaving the air I don't have
oxygen oh no I have to bring the oxygen
with me
oh this is getting more expensive all
the time
okay so here you go so the do you
remember the Artemis and the space
shuttle has two solid rocket boosters on
the side okay
the two boosters and then it releases
them all right right those two boosters
burn air
with their mixture
when the rocket gets high enough they're
done
we can't have them trying to work where
there's little air because what's the
point of that
so you get to use the free air to launch
the rocket at its lowest level through
the atmosphere where there's plenty of
oxygen right then they drop away and
anything that happens after that needs
its own oxidizer
and the fuel tanks that not only started
burning at the base on the Launchpad but
continue in orbit is the larger tank
that has two tank containers
one of them holds hydrogen the other
holds oxygen
and the hydrogen tank is twice as big as
the oxygen tank
okay so when I mix them what's the
mixture
sounds a little bit like H2O
oh
well yes so when I mix hydrogen and
oxygen it is highly exothermic
meaning it releases
tons of energy and the and the at the
exhaust is water
oh wow water
so so so we have this incredible uh you
know propellant
that the byproduct is water
yes why doesn't everything run on that
I love
one in Chuck's head
I'm just saying okay okay
there isn't hydrogen just laying around
okay okay that's it but it's everywhere
in water but pure hydrogen is just so
you have to get the hydrogen so you're
gonna get it from the water to begin
with
and guess how much energy it takes to
separate the H2 from the o
more than it does to put a rocket
okay so
so
the energy it takes to separate the
hydrogen oxygen it is slightly more than
you're going to get back by recombining
the hydrogen in the oxygen I see
yeah that so it's not quite an equal
thing but that's how you get your
hydrogen fuel it sucks it totally it
sucks and we gonna get that energy from
is it a a oil plant or whatever you know
you could you can use solar power to do
that by the way and so but I'm just
saying there's no such thing as a free
lunch
that's all and by the way they use uh
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen
because that's it's much denser you get
way more fuel than if it's just gaseous
hydrogen and gaseous oxygen right but
liquid hydrogen is liquid at like four
is that I forgot the number but low
single digit Kelvin temperature oh wow
okay we got a whole other explainer on
Kelvin low single digits so the the
whole thing is chilled
and that's why you look at some launch
um videos of of the Saturn V rocket you
see this ice falling off the sides yes
it's Florida where the hell's the ice
come from because this stuff is cold all
right keeping liquid oxygen in liquid
hydrogen so that when they combine you
have the maximum number of molecules to
do it get the maximum amount of
exothermic reaction and you get the
maximum thrust and according to Newton
you cannot move forward
unless you spew something else back out
the other side normally if you're going
to move in
hey yeah I'm glad you said that instead
of flatulence
that was my first thought but I was like
let's go that was your first thought
right okay let's get
let's be a little more mature yeah okay
yeah
so the point is uh unless you have
friction to help Propel you forward if
you're just trying to move through the
through space or through the air
something has to come out the back so
that you Propel for for every action is
an equal and opposite reaction reaction
and that's why you have this huge plume
coming out the other side
and so this that's the Rockets 101 for
you that's very cool just saying
well very cool and all that began like
in the early 20th century so the Russian
who did this early 20th century is
soakovsky I always mangle the name
silukovsky there we go yeah I think I
did that right he first wrote down the
rocket equation and Russia didn't look
back until
apparently according to you they ran out
of vodka then they said we don't need to
go to the Moon that's it
oh that what that was actually I lost
all the motivation I got it I got you
know when I met the head of their space
program I was on a government
um commission and we get to the guy's
office
and it's 10 o'clock in the morning and
there's like secret cabinets behind his
desk and he opens it up first vodka and
it's like okay it's 10 in the morning
I'm sorry I'm American I can't I don't
know
when in Moscow
all right that's all the time we have
for this explainer that was cool man as
always keep looking up
[Music]